Hey, I think you're going to like this.
This is a little bit of a break from the persistently
depressing news for only slightly depressing
news that also has a funny component.
So Fox News brings on a doctor and the doctor
is interviewed by anchor Martha MacCallum.
The doctor was completely unwilling to accept
even a little bit of Martha McCallum's bogus
framing of questions.
He gave her a 60 second answer.
That instantly shut down the interview, Martha
McCallum saying right away.
Thanks, doc.
We'll talk to you later.
So let me set this up for you.
This is Dr. Rishi Deci.
He's the chief medical officer at Osmosis.
Dr. Darci is an expert in infectious disease,
much like Anthony Foushee.
Dr. Deci is not just a doctor, but he is a
doctor who specializes in exactly what we're
dealing with here, the Corona virus pandemic.
Dr. Darci recently led Khan Academy's medicine
portal.
We're talking about a scholar, an academic,
a doctor, and he will not take Martha McCallum's
B.S. Martha MacCallum frames up a question
about, you know, we're told about millions
of tests being available.
Dr. Deci immediately starts just shaking his
head no.
And then in 60 seconds, explains basically
everything we need to know about the testing
fiasco.
We knew about the issue of testing for a long
time.
We knew the virus was coming.
We did nothing while South Korea did everything.
Check this out.
This is how you ensure no follow up questions
from Fox News anchors.
Now, what we hear every night is that the
tests that there are millions of tests available
and yet we don't have that pinprick blood
test that you can just sort of get, you know,
at your local doctor and no one fifteen minutes.
But yeah, they're working on it.
They should have more work on it for months.
So the fact is we knew about this from the
W.H.O. when December 30, first 2019.
So last year we knew about this.
We knew coronavirus is coming.
We knew it was a desperate disease.
We knew that person in person.
Why is it that it's this week that the FDA
finally approved these kind of new Abbott
lab testing, which, by the way, is one test
at a time?
The great test, but it's one test at a time.
It's different than the labs that are doing
mass testing.
Right.
So this is a wonderful test.
Don't get me wrong.
But it's one test for 15 minutes.
That's wonderful.
But it's not the same volume that you really
need.
This is better for kind of outpatient clinics
and things like that.
We needed this months ago.
You look at Korea, Korea, South Korea and
the U.S. had their first official confirmed
case on the same date, January 19th.
I mean, since January 19th, you look at what
South Korea did and what we did.
Their population is one sixth of ours.
Look at the cases they have.
Look at the mortality they have.
It's a trifle compared to what we're dealing
with right now because we've had a very weak
response and they had a really strong response.
Doctor, thank you.
Very interesting to talk to you, Dr. this.I.
Hope you'll come back.
As we move through this difficult period in
the country.
Dr. ASCI, thank you very much, sir.
So Martha MacCallum go silent and ends the
interview.
No follow up, just bubi back to Donald Trump's
propaganda claims.
Now, there's speculation that that delay,
when doctor decides, stopped speaking before
Martha MacCallum starts speaking was because
a producer was in her ear telling her, end
the interview and wrap it up.
That's an interestingly dramatic, romanticised
kind of narrative.
It might have just been a delay with Dr. Disguised
Connection.
We don't really know, but visually very, very
compelling.
And again, regarding the tests, this is a
really important point that Dr. Deci makes.
The Abbot Point of care tests.
That takes 15 minutes.
It's a really great thing that we have this
because it's great for health care providers
to be able to run the tests in-house rather
than having to send them out.
It reduces the amount of time that you have
to wait for any one individual test.
But it's important to understand, as Dr. Darci
points out, the machine can run one test at
a time.
The results take five to 15 minutes.
That means you can test four people per hour.
That's not good in a lot of ways, particularly
in a lot of these more densely populated areas.
So, you know, it's it's a good thing that
the test is a point of care test, that it
can all be done in-house.
But at the same time, a lot of these other
tests are done in large swaths.
You can test a huge number of samples at once.
Get a lot of people results very quickly.
If you have several hundred people that you've
tested and you can only run four per hour
through a machine.
You're still going to get a huge amount of
backup.
Any new testing capacity is good.
Very important to understand.
But Dr. Deci accurately pointing out that
as with almost everything, Donald Trump is
obviously overselling it.
We'll have more coverage of testing